[Música]
remezón político en Colombia el
presidente Gustavo Petro le pidió la
renuncia a su gabinete ministerial la
solicitud de se dio luego de que
partidos tradicionales de la política
colombiana ratificaran que no apoyan la
reforma a la salud que impulsa el
mandatario es la segunda sacudida en los
9 meses desde que Petro llegó al poder
y cerró anteriormente en Bogotá la
Cumbre internacional sobre Venezuela con
la participación de representantes de 20
países entre ellos Estados Unidos
pidieron convocar a elecciones libres
levantar las sanciones a medida que
avanzan los diálogos entre la oposición
y el gobierno y continuar con las
negociaciones en México
tras anunciar formalmente su aspiración
a la reelección y recibir críticas por
parte del expresidente Donald Trump y de
otros republicanos el presidente Joe
biden aseguró que cuatro años más son
claves para terminar el trabajo que ha
iniciado biden repetirá fórmula con
kamala Harris para ostentar la
nominación demócrata
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos esta
Informativo en Colombia porque el
presidente Gustavo Petro pidió la
renuncia de su gabinete de gobierno
según informan medios locales y
confirman las agencias F y reuters a
este medio según las primeras
informaciones el mandatario Busca un
reordenamiento de sus carteras
ministeriales esto ocurre mientras su
polémica reforma a la salud uno de los
principales ejes de su mandato ganó una
de las primeras votaciones en el
congreso a pesar de que los partidos
liberal y conservador los más
tradicionales de Colombia afirmaron que
no lo respaldarían el proyecto contó con
el respaldo de una representante liberal
y la ausencia de dos conservadores
impulsó su paso inicial Este es el
segundo cambio ministerial en los nueve
meses de gobierno de Petro además hace
menos de dos semanas le pidió la
renuncia a varios viceministros
seguimos en Bogotá porque hubo mucha
expectativa a lo largo de la jornada en
torno a las conclusiones de la
conferencia internacional sobre la
situación política en Venezuela las 20
delegaciones estuvieron de acuerdo en
tres puntos clave en torno a garantías
democráticas para realizar elecciones
levantamiento de las sanciones
internacionales que pesan sobre el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y los
diálogos en México
nuestra barras negociaciones entre el
gobierno de Venezuela y la oposición
estancadas desde 2021 ese era el
objetivo de la Cumbre que se realizó en
Bogotá con presencia de 20 países el
ministro de exteriores de Colombia
Álvaro Leiva precisó las posiciones
comunes se identificaron posiciones
comunes en torno a los siguientes temas
uno
la necesidad de Establecer un cronograma
electoral que permita la celebración de
elecciones libres transparentes y con
plenas garantías para todos los actores
venezolanos
que los pasos acordados a satisfacción
de las partes
vayan en paralelo con el levantamiento
de las distintas sanciones pero mientras
en Bogotá se discutió un levantamiento
progresivo en las sanciones el gobierno
de maduro insistió en que primero les
quiten los límites económicos para luego
seguir la conversación Venezuela reitera
la necesidad de que sean levantadas
todas y cada una de las medidas
coercitivas unilaterales y legales y
lesivas del derecho internacional que
constituyen una agresión a toda la
población venezolana
Leiva también dijo que las negociaciones
en México deben continuar de la mano de
la implementación del fondo fiduciario
único administrado por la ONU para
inversión social en Venezuela las
decisiones de la conferencia serán
compartidas con el presidente venezolano
Nicolás maduro y con la oposición
ninguna de las partes participó en el
diálogo en Bogotá la reunión fue
realizada por iniciativa del presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro Ojalá todo
comenzara por el reingreso de Venezuela
al sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos porque al final somos los
latinoamericanos los que tenemos que
decidir si vamos hacia la democracia O
sea la guerra y la confrontación otro de
los puntos de la Cumbre fue la visita
del líder opositor Juan guaidó quien
primero llegó a Colombia y luego viajó a
Miami sin participar en la conferencia
según la cancillería el venezolano
ingresó a Colombia de manera irregular
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden anunció su candidatura a la
reelección en el año 2024 la decisión
sigue generando reacciones encontradas
entre diferentes sectores políticos y de
la sociedad estadounidense uno de los
principales cuestionamientos es la edad
del mandatario quien en caso de lograr
un segundo mandato saldría de la Casa
Blanca a los 86 años
la principal reacción que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses han tenido ante el
anuncio de reelección de Joe biden han
sido los temores por la edad que el
demócrata tendrá al finalizar su
hipotético segundo mandato el cual
terminaría con 86 años
estoy un poco molesta es un poco viejo y
si no puede unirme al ejército a los 58
No creo que él deba gobernar el país a
los 80 y cuántos años tendrá 84 es
demasiado viejo definitivamente
demasiado viejo
la postulación de biden provocó que el
expresidente y actual aspirante
republicano Donald Trump de 76 años
criticará duramente su gestión y
catalogar a biden como el peor
mandatario de la historia de Estados
Unidos
una presidencia con tantas calamidades
es casi inconcebible que Joe biden ni
siquiera considerar a ser candidato a la
reelección ustedes saben lo que pasó en
la anterior elección hicieron trampa y
se robaron las elecciones pero les
prometo esto cuando debatamos y
comparemos nuestros historiales va a ser
la peor pesadilla de los radicales
demócratas porque nunca ha habido un
récord tan malo como esto y nuestro país
nunca ha estado peor
sin embargo las opiniones sobre la
gestión del demócrata son dispares en la
ciudadanía
creo que está haciendo un trabajo
fantástico creo que en este momento
probablemente sea el mejor para vencer a
Trump
creo que es un fracaso y si no estuviera
en el cargo la economía no estaría
arruinada no estaríamos en guerra con
Ucrania quiero decir Ucrania no estaría
en guerra con Rusia
biden mantendrá su actual compañera de
Fórmula kamala Harris de 58 años para su
segundo mandato para los demócratas las
situaciones delicada sino otro nombre de
peso que no sea biden intentarán
retenerla mayoría en el senado tras ser
minoría en la cámara de representantes
este miércoles se reúne el consejo de
seguridad de las Naciones Unidas para
debatir sobre la crisis de seguridad en
Haití en donde más de 400 personas han
muerto o desaparecido en los últimos
seis meses esto según datos de un
informe publicado el lunes por la red
Nacional de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos el poder de las bandas
criminales está al que se estima que
actualmente controlan un 80% del
territorio de Puerto Príncipe la capital
la más reciente rea cción fue el
linchamiento de 10 presuntos pandilleros
al encuentro en la ONU asistirá el país
vecino República Dominicana que entiende
que los niveles alarmantes de seguridad
en Haití amenazan la seguridad Nacional
Dominicana
nos vamos a México en donde algunos
migrantes se cosieron la boca en señal
de protesta ellos hacen parte del actual
caravana que primero quiere llegar a la
capital y luego ir a Estados Unidos
piden a las autoridades mexicanas que
les permitan obtener documentos
migratorios de manera legal y más
accesible además de transporte para
llegar hasta ciudad de México Asimismo
reivindicaron la protesta como forma de
solidaridad con las familias de los 40
migrantes muertos en un puesto
migratorio de Ciudad Juárez el pasado 27
de marzo
y Argentina vive una crisis de pérdida
de valor del peso frente al llamado
dólar blue el cambio paralelo e ilegal
comúnmente utilizado por la población
roza y a los 500 pesos por dólar esto en
medio de una alta inflación y la caída
de las reservas que llevan a especular
con una caída del peso oficial
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal
natalio cosoy nos contaba a qué puede
atribuirse Esta caída del cambio y cómo
está afectando a la gente en el día a
día La verdad que el gobierno señala por
ejemplo factores vinculados con
operaciones de financieras habla de la
oposición habla de la derecha queriendo
mover los mercados en un año electoral
recordemos que este año se elige
presidente en Argentina y eso tiene el
lugar del país en dificultades grandes
Pero bueno Más allá de eso esto genera
muchísimas preocupaciones muchísimas
Preocupaciones en una población que
viene arrastrando una inflación muy dura
que viene creciendo mes a mes y este
indicador el del dólar Blue si bien no
es el dólar más utilizado en la economía
en exportación en importación eso son
otros dólares con otros valores muy
distintos a este pero si es una suerte
de referencia que usa la población para
entender Dónde está parado Y cuánto vale
su dinero y en un contexto de altísima
inflación si ve además que esta
referencia que está mirando día a día
también se dispara de esta manera genera
inseguridad genera angustia y genera
mucha incertidumbre sobre una base de
incertidumbre que ya estamos viviendo en
el país vinculada como te decía con la
inflación además importante en un año
electoral así terminamos este repaso
informativo sigan conectados a France 24
[Música]